ah
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález este 2 de
noviembre fue conmemorado el día
internacional contra la impunidad para
los crímenes contra los periodistas una
fecha que nos recuerda lo difícil que es
ejercer esta labor la unesco ha alertado
sobre la alta y persistente impunidad
que hay en torno a los crímenes que
relacionan o que tienen relación con
periodistas
siendo así este el principal combustible
para que la situación no dé síntomas de
mejoría en algunas partes del mundo
principalmente en américa latina' veamos
algunas de las cifras según este reporte
de la unesco en los últimos cinco años
han sido contabilizados unos 400
asesinatos de periodistas en todo el
mundo 9 de cada 10 asesinatos a
periodistas en los últimos 14 años no ha
sido resuelto es decir que representa
una impunidad del 87 por ciento de los
casos así es como está la situación
veamos
periodistas de todo el mundo reciben
amenazas como esta cada día son las
imágenes de la campaña de la unesco para
este 2 de noviembre día internacional
para poner fin de la impunidad de los
crímenes contra periodistas
entre 2006 y 2020 más de 1200
periodistas fueron asesinados según el
organismo 9 de cada 10 casos siguen sin
resolverse judicialmente
organismos internacionales denuncian la
impunidad en los casos de trabajadores
de medios de comunicación en octubre dos
periodistas perseguidos recibieron el
premio nobel de la paz la filipina maría
reza y el ruso dmitri murátov
el comité para la protección de los
periodistas avisó entonces sobre el
peligro que entraña hoy la profesión
la situación es terrible porque los
periodistas están amenazados como nunca
antes hay cifras récord de periodistas
encarcelados la libertad de prensa está
en retroceso en casi todas partes webber
américa latina es la región más
peligrosa para el periodismo entre 2011
y 2020 139 periodistas han sido
asesinados según reporteros sin
fronteras
de la sociedad interamericana de prensa
indican que en 2021 ya han acabado con
la vida de 11 profesionales de la
comunicación
méxico es el país más violento en los
últimos días fueron asesinados dos
reporteros y como es habitual todavía no
hay ningún detenido
unesco denuncia que el 87 por ciento de
las muertes en el mundo quedan impunes
las víctimas suelen cubrir temas de
crimen organizado y suelen vivir en
pueblos pequeños
la búsqueda de la verdad es un trabajo
de riesgo en muchos lugares y como
denuncia en este día unesco la violencia
contra la profesión pone en peligro la
democracia en la libertad
no solamente está en juego la vida de
los periodistas y la labor de los
reporteros estos crímenes han
evidenciado también la falta de justicia
la falta de garantías y seguridad por
parte de las autoridades lo que
desencadena en violaciones del derecho
internacional y no menos importante
también la libertad de expresión muchos
reporteros son objetivo de gobiernos
autoritarios de grupos armados de
diferentes sectores sociales entre otros
en lo corrido del 2000 21 35
trabajadores de prensa han sido
asesinados
348 están privados de su libertad méxico
y colombia son algunos de los países con
los panoramas más críticos veamos
hace siete años sin fold y se convirtió
en el primer periodista estadounidense
en ser ejecutado por el grupo estado
islámico su decapitación filmada y su
vida en línea conmocionó al mundo para
la madre de folk y jim murió por los
valores que apreciaba
quién murió por lo que pensó que era la
verdad por lo que sintió que era
importante sintió que era un trabajo que
debía hacerse estaba soltero sentía que
podía hacerlo le encantó le encantó
escuchar lo que estaba pasando y luego
escribir la historia capturando las
imágenes para traer de vuelta al mundo
tres semanas después de la muerte de jim
ryan foley creó una fundación pidiendo
al gobierno de eeuu que hiciera más para
liberar a los rehenes reporteros o no
cada vez es más peligroso ser periodista
ya sea en este país o en todo el mundo y
creo que esto se debe principalmente a
que hay mucha desinformación ahora que
hace más difícil que la verdad salga a
la luz
camau a menos que se responsabiliza a
las personas que atacan matan y torturan
a los periodistas
de la isla al arian ha convertido en una
prioridad proteger a sus reporteros
después de 20 años de informar en
entornos hostiles ahora es ella quien
envía a los periodistas a los sitios de
peligro con protocolos de seguridad
tratamos de averiguar todo lo posible
sobre el sitio al que vamos en lugar de
simplemente lanzarnos en paracaídas y no
darnos cuenta atacados encarcelados o
asesinados la violencia en contra de los
periodistas ha aumentado en todo el
mundo en los últimos 30 años más de 1400
han sido asesinados y los perpetradores
rara vez comparecen ante la justicia
lo más lamentable
es que pese a estas denuncias es poco lo
que se avanza desde el lado de las
autoridades y tampoco de la sociedad
civil para garantizar un periodismo sin
intimidación es un periodismo libre y
cuyos casos en cuyos casos las víctimas
de crímenes pues esto la mayoría quedan
impunes de acuerdo a lo que hemos visto
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
william canela él es el jefe del área de
libertad de expresión y seguridad de
periodistas de la umh es cual se
encuentra en la ciudad de siracusa en
italia también está con nosotros carlos
jornet él es presidente de la comisión
de libertad de prensa de la sociedad
interamericana de prensa se encuentra en
la ciudad de córdoba en argentina y en
el estudio de france 24 está con
nosotros adriana hurtado ella es
presidenta de la federación colombiana
de prensa ustedes nuestros televidentes
también pueden participar en este debate
con sus comentarios y preguntas a través
de las redes sociales estamos en
facebook en instagram y en twitter nos
pueden seguir como arroba france24 y un
bajo s santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo que la etiqueta es
numeral efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales pues quiero comenzar este
debate con gillian canela en italia en
europa en preguntándole la pregunta que
se hace a esta hora los reporteros los
periodistas y también parte de la
sociedad porque la situación no cambia
porque siguen aumentando las cifras y
porque no vemos una mejoría en el
tratamiento que se le da a las denuncias
de los casos de muertes o de intimidad o
intimidación de los periodistas
hola que tal
muy buenas tardes para ustedes
de hecho como mencionabas habló desde
siracusa italia donde se encuentra
el instituto internacional
de la asociación global de miembros del
ministerio público de las fiscalías
donde justamente estamos teniendo una
discusión con fiscales de todo el mundo
sobre este punto o sea que hacer para
procurar justicia en los crímenes contra
los y las periodistas y
desafortunadamente como mencionaba no
sea ahí está esta constatación desde los
organismos internacionales incluyendo la
unesco que está cifra de impunidad
no cambia o sea hace ya varios años que
la unesco viene denunciando y llamando a
la atención a esta cifra tan alta que
mencionaban en él
donde quede nueve de cada diez casos
y no es no hay una respuesta sencilla es
un conjunto complejo de variables que es
y que explica en este este resultado
pero entre ellos está la necesidad de
que los sistemas de justicia o sea los
fiscales pero también las fuerzas
policiales y los propios jueces y juezas
tengan una mirada especial sobre la
investigación en los crímenes contra los
y las periodistas es necesario tener una
perspectiva distinta en la investigación
de estos crímenes no es el mismo
investigar otros tipos de asesinatos y
investigar en los asesinados contra
contra los y las periodistas entonces a
cada una de las explicaciones es esta la
procuración de justicia que tiene que
tener características peculiares
particulares y eso es lo que tenemos que
buscar en cooperación con los sistemas
de justicia de todos los países que
tienen estas tasas tan elevadas de
crímenes contra la libertad de expresión
de italia salto hasta argentina carlos
sus impresiones sobre por qué esta
situación no cambia que es lo que está
pasando en que estamos fallando porque
año a año presentamos este informe
hacemos el análisis vemos lo difícil de
la situación pero el panorama es igual
buenas noches antes muchas gracias por
este debate que realmente hace a una de
las formas más extremas de censura que
padece
américa y el mundo entero en este
momento
y creo que hay una mezcla de
circunstancias pero básicamente se puede
resumir en una falta de compromiso de
los gobiernos para llegar a esclarecer
estos hechos y ponerle fin creo que los
gobiernos no ponen todo el énfasis en la
investigación policial primero cuando
ocurren los hechos
antes que eso inclusive cuando los
periodistas reciben amenazas muchas
veces se los deja desprotegidos sin
suficiente
apoyo para que puedan
primero a aclararse quiénes son los que
realizan las amenazas y después
apresarlos y condenarlos pero después
cuando ocurre se concreta la amenaza no
hay una investigación seria por parte de
las fuerzas policiales y tampoco como
decía guillén de parte de fiscales y
jueces y tenemos una tasa altísima
también en américa de también cercana al
90 por ciento de hechos que no se
concretan no se logra esclarecer y esto
como decíamos de algún modo es un
cuchillo de dos filos no por un lado
genera autocensura entre los periodistas
y por el otro incentiva más actos de
violencia claro y de argentina pasamos
acá el estudio en france24 adriana
buenas noches bienvenida y quiero
conocer sus impresiones sobre este
informe también sus impresiones sobre
por qué la situación no cambia usted
está en colombia conoce muy bien la
labor de los periodistas allí y es uno
de los países más criticados y en donde
los números las cifras no son para nada
alentadoras santiago buenas noches
gracias por la invitación
yo me uno a todos los invitados también
frente a la falta realmente de una
efectiva procura de justicia y no
solamente de justicia sino que cuando no
hay realmente en toda la cadena condenas
efectivas se manda un mensaje que no
pasa nada cuando se asesina a un
periodista y esto sea porque no hay
unificación procesal hay muchos casos de
periodistas por ejemplo en nuestro caso
en colombia que terminan prescribiendo
el año pasado tuvimos cinco casos y este
ya vamos para nueve y parte de eso es
porque la inactividad procesal
adicionalmente por la falta de
profesionales realmente idóneos que
revisen todo un tema de contexto que lo
que sucede en las regiones y sobre todo
porque muchas veces se estima que el
asesinato de periodistas es a raíz de su
oficio periodístico entonces vemos
generalmente a los altos funcionarios
del estado diciendo temas como es por la
inseguridad que rodea todo el país o fue
asesinado porque tenía una amante por
temas diferentes a su ejercicio
profesional
al informe de la unesco a nosotros nos
parece muy importante como esta
reducción del 20 por ciento que ellos
han reflejado en el comparativo de los
últimos cuatro años no obstante nos
parece que esto es un pequeño aliciente
frente a una cadena que existe donde
quien es el primer objetivo para
silenciar en los periodistas y
recordemos santiago que con esto no
solamente se afecta al periodista
también a su familia y se afecta a toda
la sociedad que en últimas no termina
recibiendo la información bueno en estos
casos en particular en el de colombia
que es el que usted más conoce que tanto
hay una articulación en este tipo de
crímenes entre bandas delincuenciales en
el caso de colombia los grupos armados y
el mismo gobierno hay articulación en
esto puede que no haya mucha información
porque precisamente los casos no se
investigan a fondo pero pero los casos
que han sucedido que les evidencian a
ustedes lo primero es que el primer
mensaje de silenciamiento viene con una
amenaza es decir a los periodistas en
colombiano es que una vez le pongan una
bala encima sino que realmente viene de
una advertencia segundo muchas veces los
periodistas que tienen esquemas de
protección esto no significa que un
periodismo protegido es un periodismo
que esté libre digamos de las balas
asesinas y lo otro es que muchas veces
los periodistas sobre todo en región
sienten miedo de acudir a las mismas
autoridades por presuntas infiltraciones
de estructuras criminales en el aparato
estatal nosotros hemos conocido casos de
periodistas que prefieren no acceder a
esquemas de protección del estado por el
mismo temor que existe frente a un
gobierno que digamos tiene diferentes
autoridades pero que lamentablemente ha
perdido muchísima la confianza entre
ellos los de los periodistas
adicionalmente en santiago nosotros
creemos que todo esto tiene que ver con
el resurgimiento también de nuevas
organizaciones criminales del
resurgimiento de grupos paramilitares
pensábamos que con el acuerdo de paz iba
a haber un ambiente menos hostil para la
prensa pero por el contrario ha
aumentado y sobre todo periodistas que
cubren temas de corrupción que vienen
siendo sistemáticamente amenazados
en su informe en la investigación que
han adelantado
retomo la pregunta que le hacía a
adriana la articulación entre estos
grupos delincuenciales o los diferentes
sectores que amenazan y atentan contra
la vida de los periodistas que tanta
articulación hay con los mismos
gobiernos porque en algunos casos los
periodistas son víctimas de gobiernos
y que son dictatoriales y que pasan por
encima de los derechos y de las
libertades
si uno de las cosas que el informe ha
subrayado es un cambio comparativamente
hace ya algunos años donde los datos de
la unesco
demostraban un número más alto de
asesinatos de periodistas en zonas de
conflictos armados y hoy el mayor número
de asesinatos de periodistas en el mundo
ocurre en países donde no hay conflictos
armados
como decir oficialmente abiertos y eso
demuestra que son como como decía
adriana justamente los periodistas que
están haciendo la cobertura cotidiana de
corrupción de crímenes ambientales de
violaciones de derechos humanos etcétera
son estos los los y las periodistas que
son blanco de esta violencia ahora
cuando cuando hacemos la cuando cuando
haces la pregunta sobre el estado el
estado es una máquina muy compleja no sé
por ejemplo una de las cosas que el
relatorio que el informe de la unesco y
subraya es que hay un crecimiento por
ejemplo de otros tipos de violencia
aunque el asesinato en particular
también como subrayó adrián y es una
buena noticia ha bajado un 20%
comparativamente a los cinco años
anteriores hay un crecimiento de otros
tipos de violencia por ejemplo como de
los de la violencia contra los
periodistas que cubren protestas
sociales en este caso por ejemplo el
principal perpetrador de la violencia
son las fuerzas policiales entonces son
agentes del estado lo que no quiere
decir que es el gobierno comentó como el
todo de un de un país en particular que
está perpetrando la violencia y ahora es
muy importante tener en cuenta que los
agentes del estado tenían justamente
aquellos que debían proteger los y las
periodistas y no perpetrar la violencia
contra ellos en esta situación que estoy
subrayando de la cobertura de protestas
sociales finalmente quiero subrayar que
uno de los temas tiene que ver
justamente con los periodistas que
cubren la corrupción y el crimen
organizado en tienen en la localidad en
el interior de los países no
necesariamente las ciudades capitales y
ahí si hay una conexión con políticos
locales y etcétera entonces es otro tema
que tenemos que poner mucha atención en
intento de intentar comprender qué está
pasando pero también como tú también de
bien señalaba santiago como no tenemos
las investigaciones llegando hasta el
final hay muchos elementos que no
sabemos por qué necesitaríamos que estos
crímenes fueran realmente investigados
si carlos me surge una pregunta en este
momento tal vez usted me puede ayudar
con esa respuesta es en qué momento el
periodista en el contexto en el que
estamos de redes sociales de
globalización de pandemia en qué momento
el periodista pasó a ser o ser visto por
la sociedad y por los diferentes agentes
que la componen como un criminal y un
enemigo
bueno iba a agregar justamente eso
cuando hablamos de las complicidades de
los gobiernos o del involucramiento de
los gobiernos en la falta de protección
de los periodistas tenemos que poner
también en escena el grado de
estigmatización creciente que se realiza
desde los propios gobiernos en un país
como méxico por ejemplo que tiene una
tasa de asesinatos de periodistas
altísimas la más alta del continente y
una de las más altas del mundo
el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador
descarga diariamente sus diatribas
contra los periodistas contra la gente
que está trabajando en la tarea de
informar y además va minimizando el rol
de los organismos que habían sido
creados por el propio estado mexicano
para buscar acercar mayor protección a
los trabajadores de la comunicación por
ejemplo la comisión nacional de los
derechos humanos y el mecanismo de
protección para personas defensoras de
derechos humanos y periodistas
se han burocratizado de algún modo se
han limitado los recursos de atención y
de ningún modo están verificando el
cumplimiento en los estados digamos en
las distintas regiones de las pocas
medidas cautelares que emiten si a esto
le agregamos que con la reciente ley
orgánica de la fiscalía general de la
república de méxico se terminó de
concretar el achicamiento legal de la
fiscalía especial para la atención de
delitos contra la libertad de expresión
vemos que hay un estado que se está
retirando de esa tarea de protección y
que al mismo tiempo
estigmatizar a los periodistas lo cual
alienta el clima de violencia yo hablaba
de ese cuchillo de dos filos
que bueno no sólo lo hacen las amenazas
físicas contra los periodistas sino
también las amenazas verbales o ataques
verbales sería desde la cima del poder
político se descargan carlos justamente
le va a preguntar por el escenario de
mexico que cuáles son los ingredientes
el panorama en este país que está
llevando a que se esté presentando este
tipo
de altas cifras de ataques contra los
periodistas también leyendo algunos de
los mismos periodistas mexicanos a
través de sus columnas de opinión y
alguno de ellos decía obviamente no voy
a decir el nombre decía parece que el
estado mexicano está del lado de quienes
están atacando a los periodistas el
escenario allí se puede complicar más
adelante si el mismo estado está dejando
solo a los a los reporteros
bueno ustedes todos sabemos que en
méxico hay una presencia muy fuerte de
narcoterrorismo desde digamos del crimen
organizado en varios estados del norte
de méxico y el sur también y eso lleva a
una presión permanente sobre aquellos
periodistas que trabajan en
investigación en develar los hechos que
están concretando los delitos que se
están concretando y hay amenazas
permanentes pero si ante esas amenazas
del estado no acude para buscar
reforzarla las medidas de seguridad
claramente esas amenazas pasan a la
concreción como bien decía adriana el
recién y que es un poco lo que también
ha ocurrido en colombia y sigue
ocurriendo lamentablemente o en otros
países centroamericanos donde el
narco ha ido creciendo como honduras
como haití como de distintos países de
la región no y pongamos otro caso
extremo que es el de nicaragua donde el
estado mismo es el que lleva adelante el
encarcelamiento la persecución obliga
fuerza a los periodistas al exilio
nicaragua no no lo veo muy desarrollado
en este informe y william
precisamente porque lo en nicaragua lo
estamos viviendo en el presente de cara
a las elecciones presidenciales y como
analizar ese caso en particular donde
los periodistas guillem han tenido que
abandonar el país los medios de
comunicación han sido cerrados y muchos
de ellos se han ido al exilio incluso
también candidatos de la oposición y la
comunidad internacional no hace
absolutamente nada
y cuando no sé si sí es cierto que la
comunidad internacional no hace nada en
relación a esto a otros países por
ejemplo si ustedes miran los los
informes conjuntos de los relatores
especiales de naciones unidas- del
sistema interamericano del sistema
africano y del sistema europeo de
libertad de expresión del sistema de los
sistemas de regionales derechos humanos
más del sistema universal de naciones
unidas están haciendo hincapié en varios
de estos casos incluyendo de algunos de
los países que fueron mencionados dentro
de los límites de lo que es la política
multilateral ahora sí es importante
subrayar algunos de los puntos que no es
un fenómeno
[Música]
la mente de uno u otro país que es la
creciente presencia de lo que llamamos
de periodistas refugiados incluyendo la
unesco esta semana va a realizar un
debate de internacional justamente sobre
este punto miramos por ejemplo el
reciente caso de afganistán donde un
número significativo de periodistas
también con mucha con mucho foco en
periodistas mujeres tuvieron que dejar
el país y hoy son periodistas refugiados
en distintas partes del mundo entonces
el sistema de naciones unidas está
también particularmente preocupado con
este aspecto especial cómo proteger los
derechos de estos y de estas periodistas
que tienen que dejar sus países pero que
quieren seguir produciendo periodismo
porque esta es su función quieren seguir
informando sus nacionales sobre lo que
está pasando pero en una situación mucho
más compleja que estar en el exilio
adriana la dejaba para el final de esta
ronda del debate porque tenía una
pregunta en particular para ustedes el
caso de las mujeres en el caso
colombiano las mujeres periodistas cómo
están enfrentando la situación allí un
país muy difícil en donde ya conocemos
la situación de seguridad y el tema del
conflicto que ha venido padeciendo a lo
largo de tantas décadas pero como están
haciendo las mujeres periodistas
es muy difícil santiago sobre todo por
el aumento del ciberacoso en las redes
sociales
definitivamente siguen estigmatizando a
los periodistas los periodistas ha
quedado en medio por ejemplo de los
entornos
polarizados entre ahora por ejemplo
época preelectoral y las mujeres
periodistas generalmente son atacadas
contra su vida íntima contra sus hijos
contra su familia y muchos de estos
daños no solamente digamos constituyen
una situación para no abordar temas de
investigación que están investigando
valga la redundancia sino que muchas
veces lo que intentan es que los
periodistas por ejemplo cierren sus
redes sociales adicionalmente es muy
difícil cuando salen por ejemplo mujeres
al exilio el tema es la familia donde
quedan sus hijos donde queda su núcleo
familiar mujeres periodistas que
adicionalmente tienen que estar con
esquemas de protección que muchas veces
no tienen realmente un enfoque
diferencial unos en ciudades por ejemplo
donde el clima es 39 40 grados nos
podemos imaginar una mujer con un
chaleco antibalas con hombres escoltas
que muchas veces digamos también
empiezan a hacer blanco de posibles
ataques sexuales por parte de éstos a
sus protegidas tenemos muchos casos de
mujeres en esta situación pero
adicionalmente mujeres que por ejemplo
santiago buscan comprar un seguro de
vida y el colombia ninguna aseguradora
vende a periodistas porque supuestamente
no somos una actividad de riesgo pero
las mismas cifras de la unesco las
cifras de las organizaciones colombianas
reflejan que la situación es muy
diferente y en colombia hay una
tendencia a no investigar crímenes de
hecho tenemos un 78 por ciento cercano a
la impunidad pero mucho menos se
investigan lo que son las amenazas
enviando con esto un mensaje de qué no
pasa nada y en cuanto al género a los
medios de comunicación en colombia son
predominantemente liderados por hombres
las mujeres están en desventaja a la
hora de hacer denuncias a la hora de
expresar este tipo de situaciones que se
sabe de los casos que han conocido
ustedes generalmente en las salas de
reacción y en los diferentes
departamentos un 70 por ciento hombres y
un 30% mujeres y esto sea porque
usualmente las mujeres periodistas
tienen que decir se quedan digamos en
casa teniendo una familia o se van
exclusivamente a trabajar como
periodistas digamos que tampoco vemos
que haya en las salas de reacción un
enfoque para que hayan más mujeres
periodistas y muchas de ellas
lamentablemente se están yendo es por la
comunicación organizacional y esto es
muy preocupante porque en unos años no
solamente vamos a hablar de hombres y
mujeres en la comunicación
organizacional y qué va a pasar con la
reportería en nuestro país que es tan
importante para develar justamente
muchas verdades incómodas que los
poderosos no quieren que se conozcan
usted mencionaba adriana el tema de las
redes sociales y eso me lleva a citar
precisamente la ganadora del nobel de
paz
la filipina maría reza que hizo una
advertencia sobre lo que califica como
la armamentista ción de las redes
sociales un nuevo término que
seguramente vamos a empezar a oír mucho
que rápidamente multiplican los mensajes
de odio los mueven a través de las redes
sociales y esto genera pues un millón de
movimientos en diferentes redes sociales
contra los periodistas guillem que saben
ustedes de esta armamentista ción de las
redes sociales que han podido encontrar
en la búsqueda que han hecho en la
investigación y cómo empezar a
combatirla
sí o sea maría tiene tiene razón no sé
acá hay un tema fundamental que no
estaba tan claro por ejemplo cuando
aprobamos el plan global de naciones
unidas para la seguridad de los y las
periodistas hace 10 años que es
justamente el rol de las redes sociales
de las empresas de internet en todas en
todo este complejo rompecabezas de la
seguridad de los y las periodistas y acá
una temática clave es la ausencia de
datos sobre eso las plataformas tienen
poca transparencia en cómo manejan estos
problemas o sea qué hacen para
protegerlos y las periodistas que están
en sus redes que hacen cuando hay
denuncias de los propios periodistas de
una persona como reza por ejemplo en
relación a los ataques que reciben los
datos que tenemos justamente sobre una
investigación de violencia en línea
contra mujeres periodistas que como
decía adriana son particularmente
afectados por este fenómeno es que esta
violencia en línea contra contra
periodistas y contra mujeres en
periodistas en particular son violencias
orchestra nada social hay algo por
detrás no es que es un conjunto de
ciudadanos aislados de con de usuarios
aislados de internet que están
criticando de manera odiosa las
periodistas no son ataques que vienen de
robots que vienen de una perspectiva de
nuevo orquestada y por eso con eso
terminó es fundamental incluir las
plataformas en esta discusión es
fundamental demandar que ellas sean más
transparentes en la forma como lidian
con este tema referente a pocos minutos
para terminar el programa carlos guillen
y adriana quiero comentarles sobre ese
tribunal ciudadano que abrió esta semana
en los países bajos precisamente para
hacer frente a los asesinatos de
periodistas un tribunal que es convocado
por un grupo de organizaciones de
libertad de prensa no tiene poderes para
sancionar a los perpetradores de estos
crímenes pero si presenta la evidencia a
las instituciones judiciales de cada uno
de los países puede ser ésta una
solución que se cree en este tipo de
tribunales que garantice que por lo
menos los casos lleguen hasta las
instancias y sean tomados en cuenta como
lo ve usted carlos no quiero decir que
sea como justicia en sus propias manos
pero pero puede ser un paso para
garantizar que por lo menos los casos
lleguen
sí creo que es un tema polémico o
difícil de ver cómo se va a instrumentar
pero todo lo que ayude a plantear el
tema a motivar el debate creo que es
válido
la cip por ejemplo trabaja mucho con la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos con la propia unesco con los
organismos de las naciones unidas y lo
que busca es por un lado generar
misiones a países y trabajar en informes
especiales este año hicimos dos misiones
en forma virtual pero trabajando en
contacto con distintos representantes
uno en nicaragua y otro en cuba e
investigar los asesinatos a través de
investigaciones periodísticas y también
con nuestros vicepresidentes regionales
promover campañas públicas justamente
para que se eduque sobre la impunidad
cuáles son los mecanismos que llevan al
esta se concrete y entrenar a través de
seminarios y conferencias para ayudar a
los periodistas a disminuir los riesgos
no sé pero este tema que hablaba por
ejemplo de las redes sociales es un tema
terriblemente
actual y creciente en nicaragua se acaba
de desmontar más de 1000 perfiles de
distintos
ser funcionario o militantes cercanos al
gobierno de daniel ortega que lograré
ocupable era justamente de atacar a
periodistas y opositores en que en dos
minutos del programa quiero hacer las
conclusiones rápidamente adriana que
cree usted que va a suceder que podemos
empezar a cambiar para que el año
entrante no estemos en este mismo debate
hablando de estas cifras que ya lo he
hecho varias veces son desalentadoras yo
creo que tenemos que actuar todos
tenemos que seguir presionando a los
estados para que no se hagan los de los
que no ven los casos reales y como dice
la federación internacional de
periodistas santiago no puede haber
libertad de prensa mientras los
periodistas ejercen en un escenario de
temor de pobreza y de impunidad hay una
muy buena práctica la está instalando la
asociación nacional de periodistas de
perú y es que de los gremios y los
sindicatos de periodistas se hacen
campañas para no olvidar a nuestros
compañeros y compañeras caídos entonces
están por ejemplo pintando con murales
como recuperar la memoria a través del
arte eso lo están haciendo las
organizaciones y finalmente yo sí creo
en la necesidad desde ir acudiendo al
sistema interamericano la corte
interamericana derechos humanos nos ha
dado una estupenda noticia con el caso
de jineth bedoya y creo que es una
oportunidad histórica para que colombia
realmente tenga una política pública de
prevención y de justicia frente a casos
de periodistas un caso que merece ser
conocido a lo largo y ancho de este
planeta y ya en sus conclusiones me
quedan 30 segundos
no muy rápido y yo sí creo que él es
fundamental que toda la sociedad
comprende por eso debates como este
desde su programa son fundamentales que
los ataques a los y las periodistas son
ataques a toda la sociedad o sea las
libertad de expresión es fundamental
como un derecho en sí mismo y como un
derecho para garantizar otros derechos
entonces si las personas no se paran
para decir es basta ya no vamos a lograr
por eso hago una invitación a cada una
de las personas que nos escuchan para
decir a sus autoridades bandas no
podemos seguir con esta violencia contra
la libertad de expresión y contra la
libertad de prensa carlos muy puntual
por favor para el cierre
sí creo que claramente hay que convocar
a los gobiernos de la región sobre todo
aquellos gobiernos populistas de
izquierda o de derecha como el de jair
bolsonaro en brasil o el de andrés
manuel lópez obrador en mexico a que
dejen de instalar esos rótulos esos
clichés de la prensa es la enemiga del
pueblo la prensa es la que es la madre
de todos los males porque lo que se hace
alentar más violencia y por lo tanto se
después también dificultar la
investigación de los hechos pues a los
tres invitados del programa de hoy les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
haber compartido con nosotros sus
opiniones en torno a este tema ustedes
también pueden seguir continuando en la
programación de france 24 y dejando los
comentarios en las redes sociales sigan
con nosotros
[Música]